[Music]
stanford and stanford gsb's executive
education program has
a very distinctive philosophy of
leadership education
we really think that the best leaders
blend the analytical and the intuitive
our program is really good at giving you
strengths in both of those dimensions
one of the most powerful things about
our programs is the ability to rethink
your challenges and rethink your
problems and go back to your
organization and help people in your
organization think about and approach
their challenges really differently
here at stanford we believe that who
teaches you really matters i think
that's really the the secret sauce is
that we have these scientists right who
are going to help you think like a
scientist they're going to help you
break down your problems and think about
your problems in a different way
oftentimes leadership is lonely you have
problems in your organization that you
can't solve
by talking to people in your
organization one of the most valuable
things you get
out of an executive education program
here at stanford is a group of fellow
participants who have been through the
same experience they've developed the
same language they have the same
frameworks and they can become your
trusted advisors
going forward
joining an executive education program
it's a big investment of time and of
resources what i can tell you
is that everybody i've met who's made
that decision and has come to stanford
and gone through our programs has been
transformed my hope for people who come
through these programs is always
that they leave
thinking differently about themselves
thinking differently about their jobs
thinking differently about their
organizations and most importantly
thinking differently about how they're
going to change the world
[Music]
you